Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P We talked about the
inflation numbers last week. We talked
about food as a component of the total
inflation numbers. We talked about. By the
way, one person who wrote to me and said,
David, inflation can't be down because eggs are
expensive. I forgot to mention in that story
the following, which a caller does
mention thankfully about why eggs
specifically are pricey right now.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Carolyn from
Minnesota. Yes, ma'am. Talking about the price of
eggs. Did everybody forget we had the avian flu?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: Yes, This is one component
to why egg prices have out, has
not outperformed perform. Makes it sound good.
This is why egg prices have remained and continued
up even as inflation has declined. And this avian
flu outbreak is absolutely a component to that.
I mentioned this. You know, I get the I don't
know how I got sucked into this. I basically I,
I don't eat so many eggs that a couple bucks one
way or the other makes a difference. So I read
you really want not grass fed or whatever grass
fed is is B.S. you want 100% pasture raised eggs.
And so I fell for it and I fell for it. I mean,
it sounds pretty good to me. I can tell you the
yolks are much more orange and you do like to
see that it looks healthy. Anyway, these pasture
raised eggs that I get, they used to be like 599,
a dozen, then six, 49, then 699. Now they're up
to 749. I'm still buying them. And again, I go
through so few eggs that we're talking about a
difference of like $3 a month. But I have noticed
that the eggs have remained high and indeed the
avian flu outbreaks are a factor which hopefully
will not continue to be a factor too much longer.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
It is really easy to get the bonus show. All you
have to do is sign up at join packman dot com.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yes. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: As a member. You not only get access
to the bonus show, you get a commercial free
audio and video stream of the show every day.
You also get launching very soon. A soundboard
like mine just for members.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Your
lucky stars every day. You're not Dave Pacman.
Speaker 1: If you want to prank your friends,
if you want to do whatever it is people would
do with my soundboard by popular demand,
we are releasing the soundboard to our members
very, very soon. And so you will be able to do
things like trout essential a really great
time. We're all very mature here on the
show. Okay you sign up at join Pacman dot com.
What's on today's bonus show? The White House
and Secret Service are saying no visitor
logs for Biden's Delaware home. We don't
have them. They don't exist. You're not getting
them. Okay, this is related to the classified
document investigation. The new monument in Boston
dedicated to Martin luther and Coretta scott king
has sparked serious debate and has
widely triggered many on the right,
but has also. You have been mocked by
people on the left as well. And lastly,
the gas stove is the new battle line in American
culture wars. I am going to make an extremely
important declaration on the bonus show about my
relationship to gas stoves, present and future. I
think many in the audience will be shocked by what
I'm going to announce, but I'm going to announce
it nonetheless. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Sign up a joint account is.